[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el matrimonio entre parejas del mismo
sexo recibió los votos necesarios en el
senado de Estados Unidos para ser
aprobado como una ley federal la
decisión también protegería las uniones
interraciales tenemos ampliación de
nuestro corresponsal en Washington
en Perú congresistas opositores
presentaron la tercera moción de
vacancia contra el presidente Pedro
Castillo asegurando que el pedido Busca
salvar al país de un gobierno corrupto
con aspiraciones totalitarias Pues el
rechazo interno hacia el mandatario la
alianza del Pacífico quiso respaldarlo y
la próxima Cumbre se realizará en Lima
ampliamos con nuestro corresponsal
jornada diplomática de alto nivel sobre
la guerra en Ucrania la otan y el g7
discutieron la invasión rusa y acordaron
nuevas ayudas Para apoyar la
recuperación de la red eléctrica la
alianza transatlántica dijo que ayudará
a kiev el tiempo que sea necesario el g7
creará una Red de Datos Para apoyar Las
investigaciones sobre crímenes de guerra
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en Estados Unidos porque el
senado aprobó un proyecto de ley que
protege el matrimonio igualitario a
nivel Federal que ahora debe volver a la
cámara de representantes para su
votación definitiva la normativa
promueve que el Gobierno Federal
reconozca el matrimonio entre dos
personas del mismo sexo si es legal en
el estado donde se casaron el texto
también reconoce la libertad religiosa
evitando que se pueda obligar a
instituciones religiosas como las
iglesias a celebrar esas bodas y estas
pierden beneficios o exenciones Fiscales
por no hacerlo Cristóbal Vázquez
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense nos dio más detalles de
la decisión Del senado
fueron 61 votos a favor 36 en contra en
la cámara alta para codificar Es decir
para proteger el derecho Federal de los
estadounidenses a casarse las personas
del mismo sexo puedan casarse también se
aprobó el derecho a que personas de
razas de diferentes también puedan
casarse cuando lo deseen estas según
analistas una jugada que hacen los
demócratas Aprovechando que todavía
tienen mayoría tanto en cámara baja como
en cámara alta para poder pasar este
tipo de leyes que ya el presidente dijo
que apenas le llegara su escritorio la
firmaría republicanos reaccionaron
diciendo que pues no era necesario pasar
este tipo de leyes sin embargo después
de la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia este verano de desconecer El
derecho al aborto a nivel nacional los
demócratas han querido tomar este tipo
de medidas para proteger derechos que
según ellos son fundamentales como el
derecho al matrimonio de el mismo sexo
el presidente francés Emmanuel llegó a
Estados Unidos en la que será su Segunda
visita a Washington el jefe de estado se
reunirá el jueves con el presidente Joe
biden donde se espera que se refiere a
la ley de reducción de la inflación que
preocupa a Francia ante un posible
retorno del proteccionismo económico su
visita se da además en un contexto
internacional álgido con la guerra de
Rusia contra Ucrania como pelona de
fondo
y Hoy hubo una noticia importante que se
entró la atención en Estados Unidos
porque un Jurado Federal declaró
culpable de Conspiración para cometerse
adición al fundador del grupo de extrema
derecha out keepers por su papel en el
asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 se trata de Stuart roads esto en
medio del juicio que inició el pasado 3
de octubre el que también fueron
absueltos otros tres integrantes de esa
organización el proceso buscado
establecer el papel que desempeñaron los
acusados en su intento por detener el
proceso de ratificación en el congreso
de la Victoria electoral de Joe biden
continuamos ahora en Perú donde por
tercera ocasión legisladores presentaron
una moción de destitución en contra del
presidente Pedro Castillo esta vez se
trata de un diputado opositor que
asegura que el gobierno de castillos
corrupto y tiene aspiraciones
totalitarias previamente conversamos con
Francisco Zacarías nuestro corresponsal
de France 24 en Perú nos comentó si hay
posibilidad de que prospere esta moción
de destitución para el congresista
Edward Málaga autor este tercer pedido
de vacancia presidencial contra el
presidente Pedro Castillo existe un
irresponsable desmantelamiento del
Estado peruano con personas que no son
idóneas para ejercer los cargos y están
ejerciendo función pública en las
instituciones del estado que han
comenzado a tomar estos puestos y además
esto se configura en una situación que
se señala en esta pedido de vacancia
presidencial que configura la permanente
incapacidad moral del presidente Pedro
Castillo porque
afirma que existen graves vínculos con
actos de corrupción para que esa
denuncia o mejor dicho para que esta
moción de vacancia presidencial surja
efecto se requieren 87 votos hasta el
momento solamente se han juntado 67
votos de los congresistas es por eso que
el presidente del parlamento José
Williams ha citado a junta de portavoces
esta noche para tratar de conseguir los
votos que hacen falta finalmente la
Cumbre de la alianza del Pacífico se
celebrará en Lima una medida de apoyo de
los miembros de esa organización al
presidente de Perú Pedro Castillo
recordemos que el congreso peruano le
impidió al mandatario viajar a México
donde estaba inicialmente previsto el
encuentro el movimiento llega en un
momento en que por primera vez los jefes
de estado de los cuatro países de la
alianza están alineados a la izquierda
cambiamos de tema y continuamos con
información sobre la guerra en Ucrania
esta fue una jornada cargada de
diplomacia los cancilleres de la otan y
los ministros de Justicia del 7 Se
reunieron para acordar nuevas medidas de
apoyo con el fin de restaurar la red
eléctrica ucraniana que según lleva
resultado gravemente afectada por los
bombardeos rusos lluis Muñoz tiene los
detalles
jornada diplomática de alto voltaje la
otan reunión bucarest en una cumbre de
dos días a los cancilleres de la alianza
con la Guerra de Ucrania como telón de
fondo
el presidente Putin Está tratando de
usar el invierno como arma para obligar
a los ucranianos a congelarse o huir
Está tratando de doblegar la voluntad
del valiente pueblo ucraniano
people Estados Unidos entregará 53
millones de dólares para comprar equipos
de red eléctrica promesas a las que se
sumaron el resto de ministros de
exteriores para ayudar a Ucrania de
forma económica práctica y política la
alianza de la otan está brindando un
apoyo sin precedentes y hoy los aliados
hicieron compromisos adicionales para el
paquete de asistencia integral de la
otan para Ucrania
también hubo cumbre en Berlín los
ministros de Justicia del g7 se
reunieron por primera vez en la historia
lo hicieron junto a Fiscales de la Corte
Penal Internacional la Unión Europea y
Ucrania Uy nosotros como ucranianos
entendemos que el crimen de agresión
como crimen primario crimen de guerra
primario cometido por la federación de
Rusia debe ser punible a nivel
internacional
seguros En ningún lugar donde podamos
detenerlos los llevaremos ante la
justicia en estricto cumplimiento del
principio de juicio justo ningún crimen
de guerra debe quedar impune Ese es el
mensaje hoy
todo esto cuando Rusia se retiró de las
conversaciones con Estados Unidos para
el desarme nuclear acusan a Washington
de un comportamiento antirruso tóxico
el invierno está a la vuelta de la
esquina en el hemisferio norte y quiebre
registró una Nevada Este martes lo que
llegó al gobierno ucraniano activar los
llamados lugares calientes sitios donde
las personas que han sufrido cortes en
la electricidad pueden acceder a
calefacción Catalina Gómez Ángel
corresponsal de France 24 nos amplía los
detalles
es para noches frías como estas que
nieva en kiev que se han creado Estos
espacios especiales especialmente en
esas noches en las que no hay
electricidad como sucedió días después
de ese ataque la semana pasada que dejó
no solamente oscura la capital kiev sino
a la gran parte del país desde entonces
se han creado estos centros llamados
centros invisibles donde aquellos que no
tengan electricidad que no tengan
calefacción y que no tenga agua puedan
venir a pasar y a buscar resguardo aquí
les dan lo básico para sobrevivir
durante estas horas de los ataques Aquí
tienen agua caliente Aquí tienen té Aquí
tienen café y aquí está destinado
siempre dos personas están en este
momento esperando esta es una noche en
la cual hay electricidad al menos en
esta parte de la ciudad Así que no hay
personas Pero ellos están esperando
si se recrudecen los ataques como lo ha
anunciado el presidente
bolodomir selenski esto pueda llegar
pues albergar a muchísimas personas ya
que estamos en un lugar estratégico de
la ciudad es interesante porque está
bastante bien equipado aquí no solamente
están pues Estos salones donde pueden
sentarse cargar los celulares sino que
hay un salón especial para recibir a los
niños para cambiarlos para jugar hay
otro donde pueden dormir también hay
baños tanto para hombres como para
mujeres y también pues obviamente es
equipado con calefacción con agua
caliente en el caso que sea necesario Y
es que lo que está esperando No
solamente quiere sino el resto del país
es que estos ataques contra la capacidad
energética aumenten en los próximos días
y semanas porque como anunciado el
presidente bolodomir selenski aquí se
está haciendo es una guerra
contra la población
abusando del frío que se viene por
delante
hoy 29 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional de solidaridad con el
pueblo de Palestina hace 75 años la
asamblea general de las Naciones Unidas
aprobó la resolución que estipulaba la
creación de un estado judío y un estado
árabe en Palestina El Aniversario llega
en un momento de recrudecimiento del
conflicto derivado de la ocupación
israelí de hecho hoy cinco jóvenes
murieron a manos del ejército de Israel
este 2022 está haciendo el año más
mortífero para los palestinos de los
territorios ocupados un escenario que se
complica ante la inminente investidura
del gobierno ultraderechista y Ultra
ortodoxo de Israel liderado por Benjamin
de tallao conversamos con Ezequiel
Coppel politólogo que nos habló de Por
qué la comunidad internacional no impone
sanciones contra Israel e incluso países
como Estados Unidos le proporcionan
apoyo militar
creo que es complicado Yo creo que es
verdad mucha gente marca como una
especie de doble moral del mundo con
respecto al conflicto horario palestino
y nombran que por ejemplo el mundo está
Unido contra la ocupación rusa de
Ucrania pero no así con la
contracupación que ya llega más de medio
siglo y realizó Jordania es complicado
yo creo que
gran parte de lo que se denomina las
bará israelí lo que es parte de lo que
es relaciones públicas israelíes o
propaganda israelí asocia el conflicto a
una especie de odio milenario de los
áreas de los judíos cuando especialmente
es un poquito territorial Yo creo que
esa idea esa idea de propaganda ha
penetrado por otro lado también me
gustaría decir que hasta el día de hoy a
pesar de que Estados Unidos no ha
demostrado haber sido un mediador justo
porque siempre ha inclinado un poco la
balanza hacia el lado israelí es el
único mediador que de alguna manera
puede convencerlos y realidad de hacer
algo es decir muchas veces se dice que
Estados Unidos tiene que salir del papel
del Mirador porque no es justo porque
tira más para el lado israelí que para
el lado palestino pero lo interesante es
pensar que se entraría otro mediador
como Rusia como china directamente no
tendrían ninguna posibilidad de
presionarlos y relieves el museo
harryman de Londres devolvió a Nigeria
piezas que fueron saqueadas por soldados
británicos en el siglo 19 las
autoridades de ese país esperan que el
gesto sirva para presionar a otros
museos a tomar la misma decisión Juan
Pablo lucumí con los detalles
un pequeño Museo del sureste de Londres
comenzó el proceso oficial de devolución
de elementos saqueados en Nigeria se
trata de los bronces de benín uno de los
artículos más preciados para el país
africano arrebatado por la corona
británica la devolución es la respuesta
a la petición de la Comisión Nacional de
museos y monumentos de Nigeria las
acciones recibidas como un gesto de
moral apropiada para las autoridades
nigerianas
creo que si la mayoría de museos ahora
están involucrados en la repatriación de
los objetos saqueados porque los otros
museos están simplemente observando
sentados allá afuera si ven que esto
está sucediendo en la mayoría de museos
importantes de todo el mundo Entonces
todos los demás deberían devolver los
objetos saqueados según los registros
los artefactos fueron incautados en 1897
durante una incursión militar británica
junto con otros miles de artículos y
terminaron en museos de Europa y Estados
Unidos El acuerdo entre ambas partes
asegura que seis de los artefactos serán
repatriados en Nigeria mientras 66 de
ellos permanecerán en calidad de
préstamo en el Museo de orliman en
Londres el consenso abrumador fue que
los objetos habían sido saqueados y como
tales deben ser devueltos sobre la base
de que fueron adquiridos por la fuerza y
bajo coacción las autoridades nigerianas
esperan que estas devoluciones aumenten
la presión sobre el museo británico de
Londres el cual posee por mucho la
colección más grande y significativa de
bronces de veneno
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 Les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega
Andrés espinal con toda la información
de nuestra red de corresponsales en el
mundo feliz noche para todos
[Música]